foreign
with this because this is part of this
discussion we're having here's the
headline a lack of credit history
creates Financial obstacles for
immigrants and as a first generation
American whose parents were immigrants I
resonated this because I went oh my gosh
this is my parents story here's what it
says what may seem like an immigrant
cliche actually happens every day
foreigners arrive in the U.S with Big
Dreams and a few dollar bills in their
wallet that was true for both of us
reporting the story
and it goes on to say the U.S economy
counts on you to borrow money and stay
into debt and the epitome of all this is
the credit score which often snares
newcomers into a financial Catch-22
penalizing a lack of dead history and
pushing many to take confusing sometimes
costly measures oh besides that we need
to support the U.S economy because
that's our first goal
my first goal is not to support the U.S
economy my first goal is to make sure
the Ramsey family is taken care of the
US economy will have to deal with itself
they'll figure it out so that's what it
counts on you it counts on you welcome
to America stay in debt you need a
credit score to live here that's pretty
much what they tell you and so how do
you get a credit score Dave well you got
to go into debt to get the score so you
can go into more debt to get the score
so you can go into that to get the score
oh my God so the Great American dream
when you add
um this method to it turns into the
Great American Nightmare for a lot of
first generation immigrants oh yeah and
they play this game because they were
told they had to play the game and then
they realize wait where's the American
dream we're broke up to our eyeballs in
car loans credit cards personal loans
student loans medical debt mortgages now
your family was Middle Eastern yes so uh
we've done a lot of work in the Spanish
Community uh people coming from various
countries uh in the Latin world and a
lot of them don't have a trust of banks
and so they haven't fallen for this if
they're particularly their entry-level
socio-economic okay now they come in
higher heavier cash users yeah the
heavier complete it's under the bed it's
literally in a box under the bed I mean
I'm not kidding it's not a metaphor it's
a shoe box with hundred dollar bills you
know the bet because they don't trust
Banks to not go broke from because they
came from a Banana Republic of some kind
that all the bank banking system was not
reliable and so they don't fall for this
because they're not going to go into
debt now what they do fall for is other
things Title Pawn and other crap you
know but uh but what happens is people
like your mom and dad they often get
Americanized in the worst ways
they adapt to the culture and part of
that is this toxic money culture that
says you got to go into debt and where
does that lead us well U.S household
debt now surpasses 17 trillion dollars
now here's what's interesting Dave
comparing that to the European Union
which has more households and yet less
than half of that amount in debt which
tells me that debt is the most
aggressively marketed product in
American history and we are so good
America is number one in a lot of things
and debt is one of them marketing is one
of them and here's a great quote from a
Stanford economic sociologist being
financially responsible in the US has
come to mean borrow and repay
that pretty much sums up how you've been
doing this for 30 years Dave
everyone was told if you want to be
financially responsible borrow money and
repay it back and do that over and over
again until you die and then maybe one
day you'll hopefully be able to retire
insane so I think it's time for a
cultural shift here well I yeah you just
want to you want to say hey don't you
know you got here for the Statue of
Liberty don't give up your Liberty
um don't don't sign up for slavery come
here for freedom and you lose it yeah
the first day sign up for master
card
that's your first thing to do once
you're looking for Liberty but you go
get a master first thing
yeah that's not our American distress we
can sign up for that our discovering
bondage yeah all for two percent back
don't forget
two dollars land of the free home of the
broke